hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter four of book five of theodore
dostoevsky's the brothers karamazov
ivan karamazov tells the story of this
young swiss boy eventually a young swiss
man
richard who winds up being executed
for crimes that he commits
and he's doing so within the framework
of talking about
cruelty and suffering imposed upon
children and in this case there is some
physical abuse
but a lot of it has to do much more
with an almost deliberate neglect
a deprivation of what children
ought to have and the indifference
not only by his adopted parents
if you want to call them parents but by
the larger society and then the
switch kind of flipping in a way
while he's in prison and embraces
christianity but only going so far
and this is an interesting one because
throughout the rest of the
chapter ivan is talking about
cases of children who are suffering and
in many cases
dying as as a result of the abuse that's
that's inflicted upon them
in this case we have somebody who grows
up
and grows up as you could say
the product of what has been
done to him and what has been taken away
from him
i want to read one line that kind of
brings this across he says
[Music]
this is what the townspeople of geneva
are saying
though it's not your fault that you knew
nothing of the lord when you envied the
swine their food and were beaten for
stealing
it which was very bad for its forbidden
to steal still you have shed blood and
must die so because of how
screwed up his childhood was because of
the positive abuse
and the negative abuse of neglect
of treating him essentially as a thing
rather than a human being
he's stuck with this fate of
you know having done these these
terrible crimes
and even though he's embraced
christianity even though now he
understands
he still has to suffer for what he did
prior to that not knowing it so the
story goes like this
richard is an illegitimate child who
as he says at the age of six was
presented by his parents to swiss
mountain shepherds
who brought him up to work for them and
i want to dwell on this a little bit
so he had parents uh he's he's you know
born out of wedlock he's a bastard
there's there's of course
a lot of social stigma attached to that
so
in some ways being fostered by some
legitimate couple would be a step
up but in many cases that's not how
things turned out and i i'd like to
mention that
this sort of fostering is not something
that you know
is only back there in old swiss villages
that was going on here in the midwest
here in wisconsin
well into the 20th century as a matter
of fact
you can read accounts of children who
are either born
out of wedlock or were orphaned
or even were not even orphaned but just
given to the orphanage
i know of a case for example of somebody
who's
uh they were irish and their their horse
farm was burnt down here in wisconsin by
the ku klux klan
on christmas eve leaving only
the farmhouse the mother committed
suicide the next day
the children were all farmed out to
relatives except for the youngest son
for whom there wasn't any any place and
the father just went off who knows where
the youngest son was placed with a
couple as essentially an indentured
servant
beaten neglected terribly and there's
case after case after case like this
there was no legal recourse these
children were essentially property and
this went on
well into the 20th century here in rural
wisconsin
and in many other places things like
this continue
so richard is given to some shepherds
and you know
if your idea of shepherds is this you
know wonderful bucolic
life that people often depict shepherds
like no
sheep herding sucks it is a lot of hard
work
agricultural work in general is hard
work and being a shepherd means taking
these flocks
out into the places where they can graze
making sure the wolves don't don't catch
them trying to catch you know whatever
sheep are doing stupid things because
sheep are pretty
pretty foolish uh and then bringing them
back at night you're exposed to the
elements
oftentimes you know you you eat whatever
you can find
and so this is a boy this is a
six-year-old boy
he writes he grew up among them like a
little wild beast
the shepherds taught him nothing
on the contrary by the time he was seven
they were already sending him out to
tend the flocks and the cold
and the wet with almost no clothes and
almost
nothing to eat no education
no bringing up no affection no anything
from these people that he's living with
he's put to work
he's out there in the elements
switzerland is in the mountains
it gets cold up there
it's even cold sometimes in the
summertime right and
nothing to eat he has to fend for
himself
and it goes a little bit further he says
none of them stop to think or repent of
doing so
on the contrary they consider themselves
entirely within their rights for richard
had been presented to them
as an object they didn't think it
necessary
to feed him he's essentially just
a working thing he's a slave
essentially a tool that has
a mind and a soul and can do the things
they want and they don't even give it
what what it needs there's so much
going on here they're not just depriving
him of food
clothing they're depriving him of even
being treated as a human being
and let alone you know education and
affection
so richard says like the prodigal son in
the gospel he wanted terribly to eat at
least the mash given to the pigs
being fattened for market he was not
even given that and was beaten when he
stole from the pigs
so he spent his whole childhood in his
youth until he grew up and gathered
strength went out to steal for
himself he takes things into his own
hand
own hands he he says well they're not
going to take care of me i have to take
care of myself
and that's how he actually survives
he steals eventually he becomes you know
emancipated becomes a day laborer
spends his earnings on drink lived like
a monster
how else would he live he doesn't know
anything else ends by killing some old
man and robbing him and so they
they caught him they tried him and they
condemned him
to death now this is where his life
drastically changes up until now the
people
around him don't care about him not just
his
foster parents who turn him out to work
and treat him as if he's
merely an object but everybody else who
witnesses this
doesn't care they they're not affected
by it they're like well that's somebody
else's
business this child is obviously in rags
emaciated you know stuck out there
eight nine years old hurting all these
sheep
not my problem now
in prison he says he was immediately
surrounded by
pastors and members of various christian
brotherhoods
philanthropic ladies and so on
in prison they taught him to read and
write began expounding the gospel to him
exhorted him persuaded him pushed him
pestered him urged him and he finally
solemnly
confessed his crime he repented he wrote
to the court himself saying he was a
monster
and then at last he'd been deemed worthy
of being illumined by the lord and of
receiving
grace so he's had you know whether it's
real or not he's had he's at least on
record as having had a conversion
it appears that it is real from what
follows and this happens because people
for the first time
care about him at least in some way they
don't
care about him necessarily in all the
ways that he should be cared about
but they do that and this is something
that you can see in prisons there are
many
volunteers who do indeed go into
prisons and preach the gospel to them
teach them how to read and write
there's all sorts of other skills people
can learn in prison that i think can
sometimes be remunerative
learning how to do you know air
conditioning
culinary arts gets taught in prison you
know all sorts of other things like that
but the question that we have to ask
here is
are are these more about the people
getting to come in
and do what they want to do or is it
really about the
man who once was an abused child
now a damaged human being
who is ostensibly being helped
and ivan goes on further he says
all of geneva was stirred all of pious
and philanthropic geneva
all that was lofty and well-bred rushed
to him in prison
richard was kissed embraced you are our
brother grace is descended upon you
so now it's not just the busybodies and
the religious people per se it's
everybody
he's like a hero but a hero who has to
stay in prison
because he committed that crime a crime
that he committed in part because
he didn't know really any better because
he was raised so poorly by these people
who abused him
so now all of geneva is saying oh this
this guy is so amazing so
great and richard you know has a
response
he wept with emotion yes grace has
depended upon me
through before through all my childhood
and youth i was glad to eat swine's food
now grace has descended upon me i too
am dying in the lord and it's not dying
in the lord
in sort of a i'm dying to sin
it's literally he's going to die because
he's going to be
executed they say here we come back to
it yes richard die in the lord
you have shed blood and must die in the
lord it's not your fault you knew
nothing of the lord when you envied the
swine their food
and were beaten for stealing it but
still you've shed blood
and must die so there's no mercy for him
there is mercy in the sense of well
we'll teach you christianity
we'll preach you the gospel we'll you
know love you
and and laud you and and surround you
with with people who are embracing you
but you're still gonna die buddy
because you're still a criminal and
it goes on and says um
little rit limp richard weeps and all
the while keeps repeating
this is the best day of my life i am
going to the lord
moving towards the scaffold
in carriages and on foot following the
card of shame that's bearing richard
they arrive at the scaffold
die brother they call out to richard die
in the lord for grace is descended upon
you too
covered with the kisses of his brothers
he's dragged up under the scaffold laid
on the guillotine and his head is
whacked off
in brotherly fashion for as much as
grace is dependent upon
descended upon him too and this is like
in in a pamphlet that was being
distributed in russia according to ivan
by lutheran agencies that were trying to
use this as as sort of a teaching case
what does it actually teach us
nobody really stops and says should we
kill this guy
is anything being rectified by
you know there's justice being done in
the case of the old man who's killed
but this isn't like somebody who
you know was raised in a decent
household
and shows between good and evil in a
sense
richard is still a child when he commits
this this horrible crime
and we have to ask well what does it
mean for grace
to descend upon you it means for richard
while i get to go to heaven in heaven
that he has you know
basically no idea about
and everyone else gets to talk about
this wonderful
repentant criminal but
working in the background is this
horrific abuse
that has taken place and is not in any
way being
redeemed or recuperated through
his embrace of the gospel and their
execution of him
you